[Applause]
thank you very much Bishop John and
thank you all for inviting me here it's
a great honor for me to be able to
address you today on such an topic of
importance uh we see practically every
day horrific new stories about the
persecution of Christians in uh the
Middle East and elsewhere in the Islamic
world and I thought that today it would
be useful in order to help you to
understand why this is all happening to
uh take you through the Islamic view of
Christians and Christianity as per the
Islamic holy book the Quran I know that
you had a Bible study earlier and so I
thought it would be a good time to have
a little Quran study and so uh I know
you all have yours if you'd open your
qurans to uh chapter 5:
46 uh you'll see that the Quran actually
says something that is often cited
by spokesmen who are hastening to tell
us that they really isn't any problem
and that ultimately there is a great
welcoming Spirit within Islam for
Christians and Christianity and uh
chapter 5: 46 it says and we sent Jesus
the son of Mary after those prophets
confirming the truth of whatever there
still remained of the Torah and we gave
him the go gospel wherein is guidance
and
light wherein is guidance and light in
the gospel and so you would think this
is a very generous ecumenical statement
that the gospel contains guidance and
light and so a Christian can look at
that and say well this is great this is
a a holy book of another religion that
in a rather unprecedented and unusual
manner is recognizing the truth of the
holy book of a different
religion but there's more
very shortly after that passage we can
go to chapter 5: 65 and just in case you
don't have your Quran I'll read it for
you uh had the people of the book that's
the quran's term primarily for Jews and
Christians had the people of the book
only believed and been
God-fearing we surely we being God
surely would have effaced from them
their evil deeds and caused them to
enter The Gardens of bliss okay so what
it is what is it that the people of the
book that is the the Jews and the
Christians had to do in order to enter
The Gardens of bliss had the people of
the book it goes on observed the Torah
and the
gospel and all that had been revealed to
them from their lord sustenance would
have been showered over them from above
and would have risen from beneath their
feet some among them in certainly keep
to the right path but many of them do
things that are evil so now we have two
groups of Christians some that are on
the right path and some that do evil and
If Only They had kept to if had the
people of the book observed the Torah
and the gospel then everything would
have been okay so it seems as if there's
some of these people of the book some of
the Christians who don't observe what's
in the
gospel and they are obviously the ones
on the wrong path but what is actually
what has actually gone wrong in their
way of thinking according to the on in
chap 5:1 17 and 72 it repeats it twice
the statement that unbelievers are those
who say Allah is the Messiah the Son of
Mary that is those who affirm the
Divinity of Christ those who say that
Allah or God is Christ or that Christ is
God then they are unbelievers and so in
one Fell Swoop in those two passages
that passage that is actually affirmed
twice the Quran is actually saying that
the faith of all virtually all
Christians throughout history
Protestants Catholics Orthodox that
Jesus Christ is the Divine Son of God
God the son the second person of the
Trinity is a manifestation of
unbelief and of course there's more
besides in chapter 4: 171 it says they
did not kill or crucify ify him but it
appeared so unto them in other words
they thought they were crucifying him
but they weren't really which of course
takes away the cross the Resurrection
The Salvation of Christ the sacrificial
death the atonement the whole heart of
Christianity is gone many many other
passages in the Quran affirm very
strongly that it is against the
Transcendent Majesty of God to say that
he would have a son that for him to have
a son would be to imply some insuff
efficiency on his part that is the
Assumption I don't think that that's
really a true statement regarding
fatherhood on a human level or when
we're talking about the Divinity but
nonetheless this is what is
affirmed so you have I think I said the
wrong number I'm sorry 4157 is about the
crucifixion if you're taking notes but
what we have in all this and in so many
other passages such as 5: 1116 when a
lot actually questions Jesus about what
he taught says in the in the Hereafter
Allah will say Jesus Son of Mary Did you
say to people take me and my mother as
Gods besides Allah this is the quran's
understanding of the Trinity not the
father and the Son and the Holy Spirit
but uh God Jesus and Mary and God asks
him Allah asks him did you tell your
followers to worship you and your mother
as God along with me and Jesus answers
glory to you it was not for me to say
what I had no right to say if I had said
so you would have known it you know all
that is within my mind whereas I do not
know what is within yours obviously then
Jesus is not God and is not part of the
godhead
so we have here
obviously a some very serious
theological disagreements between Islam
and all sects and schools of thought
within Christianity that are mainstream
and have been throughout
history however all that amounts to so
far is just essentially that a
theological disagreement of which there
are many of course and Christians of
course have theological disagreements
among themselves and so this in itself
would not account for the persecution by
itself the problem of course is that in
the Islamic context there is a great
deal more to it bes Ides that when you
have theological disagreements then they
take on a very different character when
combined with the Islamic view that the
Muslims are the executors of the will of
Allah and this is a very important point
in in in the scriptures we hear
vengeance is mine says the Lord I will
repay and Christians are not to take
revenge not to avenge themselves in any
way
according to the scriptures in the Quran
you have exactly the opposite teaching
as a matter of fact you have the
explicit obligation given to Muslims to
be the executors of God's Wrath on Earth
in chapter 9:
74 it says speaking about unbelievers
they are spiteful against Muslims for no
other reason than that Allah and his
Messengers have enriched them through
his bounty so if they repent it will be
for their own good but if they turn away
Allah will sternly punish them in this
world and in the
Hereafter so in other words the
unbelievers will not only be going to
hell but will be punished in this world
and how will God punish the unbelievers
In This World by means of the
Muslims in chapter 9 ver14
it
says make war on them Allah will
chastise them through you Allah will
chastise them through you that God in
other words in the Islamic scheme of
things will use the Believers the Muslim
Believers to punish those who deviate
from credal
Orthodoxy he will chastise them through
you so this creates you see an
obligation for a Pious and knowledgeable
mus and understands it to be the perfect
word of God that existed forever with
God in paradise and then was delivered
in perfect form to
Muhammad and has been preserved
throughout the ages down to our present
day this creates in such a person a
feeling that he has a responsibility
before God to fight against those who
have rejected the faith who have as the
Christians have deviated from the truth
that the of the
Gospel they have to be punished in this
world and in the next and done and the
Muslims have to do the
punishing you see in the Islamic scheme
of things Jesus was a Muslim Prophet who
taught
Islam then the gospel was guidance and
light but afterward his followers came
along and they twisted and hijacked the
original perfect teach teachings of
Jesus that corresponded exactly with the
teachings of Muhammad who would come
later and they changed them into
something in which Jesus dies on a cross
and is the Son of God and part of the
Trinity thus outraging the truth of the
message of Christ and placing them into
the camp of the
unbelievers who have to then be punished
by the hand of God working through his
true
believers so when when we see this
persecution in the Middle East when we
see the Islamic State or Isis as it's
popularly known Waging War against the
Christians driving them out of lands
that they have lived in for
centuries the people who are doing that
believe that they are carrying out a
Divine
responsibility something that will bring
them blessings from
God you may recall that Jesus himself
said in the Gospel of John
the time will come when men will kill
you and think they're offering service
to God that time is upon us
now the time will come when men will
kill you and think they're offering
service to God that is happening every
day in Iraq in Syria and elsewhere now
there's one obvious objection that may
be in your minds at this point and that
is this that the Christians who were for
example driven out of
mosul the caldan Catholic Archbishop of
mosul very large and important city in
Iraq and a city that's had a Christian
presence since the beginning of
Christianity the called calan Catholic
Archbishop of mosul said a few months
ago he said my entire
dasis my entire dasis has been lost to
Islam and the same thing will happen to
the Christians in Europe and the United
States if they don't wake up to what's
happening now the objection is this the
entire dasis of which the Archbishop of
mosul was speaking was under Islamic
rule for almost 14400 years and so why
is it only now that the Christians have
been so violently persecuted and driven
out why is it that 15 years ago there
was a Christian population of well over
a million in Iraq and now they have
almost all
gone and there only a few to maybe a
couple hundred thousand if that left in
the country and more leaving all the
time why is this happening now if this
is all about the Quran if this is all
about Islamic ideas of being executing
the wrath of Allah against the
unbelievers then how is it that Muslims
and Christians lived in relative peace
and Harmony in Iraq for all those
centuries well that has to do with once
again the Quran and other aspects of
Islamic theology the Quran
9:29 it says fight against those who do
not obey Allah and his messenger and do
not forbid what he has
forbidden even if they are of the people
of the book remember that's the Jews and
Christians
mainly until they pay the gizia with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued gizia is a tax and so the
Christians have to be fought against
until they pay a tax and are subdued
subjugated under the rule of Islam
once they do that once they
submit then they're allowed essentially
to live in peace this is Islamic
law the submission however comes on the
basis of an institutionalized
discrimination a second class status
that is very carefully detailed in
Islamic law the demies the protected
people they're called or the DI zumies
they are not allowed to hold authority
over Muslims so they only have the most
menial jobs in society and you can even
see to this day in Pakistan the
colloquial term the slang name for
Christians in the society is street
sweepers and you some I sometimes come
across news stories where a Muslim is
saying these sweepers they were they
were being insolent and they're called
street sweepers because that's the kinds
of jobs they can get they can't get a
job where they hold authority over a
Muslim that would be contrary to Islamic
law Christians in the is under the rule
of Islamic law who have been subjugated
as per that Quran verse also cannot
build new churches or repair old ones so
their communities are always in a
Perpetual state of decline they cannot
uh hold they
cannot not only can they not build new
churches or repair old ones but they can
you have men can I always I I'm sorry
I'm stopping here because I always I
always say misstate this and I want to
be careful to say it properly Muslim
women cannot marry non-muslim men but
Muslim men can marry non-muslim women
and you sometimes hear Islamic
apologists in the west say uh you
see Islam is very ecumenical and
generous because Muslim men can marry
non-muslim women and they don't have to
convert isn't that wonderful well that
might be wonderful but the reality is
that it's another
supremacist manifestation that Muslim
men can marry non-muslim women women but
Muslim women cannot marry non-muslim men
the idea is of course the woman goes
into the man's household and the Muslim
Community is always growing whereas the
non-muslim community is always declining
it's the same impulse as behind the law
that mandates that mus uh Christians
can't build new churches or repair old
ones so you have various other
regulations in some cases throughout
history the uh Christians and the Jews
were forbidden to wear shoes to ride
horses they had had to like in the old
Jim Crow laws in the Old South the
non-muslims had to step off the street
and let the Muslims pass if the Muslims
were coming and so on all of this is
designed to remind the Christians that
they have re rebelled against the true
God and that they have strayed from the
right path and that they are suffering
in this world as well as the next
because of their rejection of Muhammad
and the Quran and
Islam but once you're in those
boundaries once you have accepted the
subjugated status the second class
status and you know that your life hangs
on the whim of the overlords and you
accept the denial of basic rights that
the dimma entails then you can
live and so the Christians who lived in
mosul for centuries under the Islamic
caliphates going back to the sth
century they lived in peace as long as
they knew their
place if they got out of line they would
be
killed and there were various periods of
relaxation just as there are in any
society under any legal system times
when it's enforced very rigorously and
times when it's not enforced so
rigorously and so there were times when
the Christians were able to even in a
relative sense Prosper particularly in
the decline of the last caliphate the uh
the C the cff is the successor of
Muhammad as the spiritual military and
political leader of the Muslims and the
kaith was the the caliphates ruled over
much of Islam the Islamic world all the
way through history up until 1924 when
the last caliphate was abolished by the
secular Turkish government but the last
caliphate the Ottoman Empire you may
know if you studied history was referred
to as the sick man of Europe in the late
19th century and the early 20th century
because it was in such a drastically
weakened State and in that period the
Western Powers at a time when the West
was much more confident about its own
principles than it is today actually
pressured the Ottomans to relax some of
these restrictions on the Christians and
to abolish some of these laws that had
mandated their second class status and
the last of them were abolished in the
year 1856 and so after
1856 in the Middle East and particularly
in Iraq which was an ottoman Province
you had Christians living in relative
peace General peace and general almost
equality with the Muslims it's never
been legal in any Muslim country even
secular turkey for Christians to prze
and try to convert Muslims but otherwise
they really were living in a uh state of
almost
equality now that brings us into modern
times and then by the time you have
Saddam Hussein there and the Iraq war
that toppled him you have very Islamic
groups both Sunni and Shiite that wanted
to restore the rule of Islamic law
wanted to restore es especially the
subjugated status of the Christians the
dimma the second class status mandated
in the Quran remember in chapter 9: 29
where it says that the Christians must
pay the gizia the tax with willing
submission and feel themselves
subdued they wanted to restore
that when Barack Obama withdrew the last
American troops from IR Iraq they had an
opportunity to do so and the Islamic
State formed out of various Sunni groups
that were fighting against B Bashar
Assad in Syria and against the Shiite
regime in Baghdad and the Islamic State
very quickly was able to gain control
over a territory larger than the size of
the United Kingdom and it still controls
that today one of the first things they
did when they went into mosul was knock
on the doors of the Christians homes and
demand the gizia the coric tax
and they painted the N the Arabic letter
the Arabic letter N for Nazarene which
is the Christians the Quran term for
Christians on the doors of the
Christians so they would know this is a
house where the Christians live we have
to make sure to collect the tax from
them the Christians didn't want to pay
the tax they hadn't paid it remember it
was abolished in 1856 so not only had
they not paid it but their parents
hadn't paid it their grandparents hadn't
paid it their great-grandparents hadn't
paid it it was out of living memory
and here come these guys demanding that
it be paid because it's in the
Quran and the Christians
refused
now that's why their lives were
forfeit once you refuse to obey once to
refuse to
submit then there's only other one one
other choice and that is you are
killed there's a a tradition a Hadith in
which Muhammad the prophet of Islam he
says when you meet the unbelievers
invite them to convert to Islam if they
refuse that invite them to pay the gizia
that is to submit and accept the second
class
status if they refuse both then fight
them if they refuse both then fight them
the Christians in mosul the Christians
in Iraq in general and in Syria they
refused to pay the tax they refused to
submit and so they were killed or they
were they were able to escape from the
area and Christian communities that had
been there for 14 00 years are now
gone this was all based on the
reassertion of konic principles and
Islamic
principles and it all comes down to that
idea that Jesus himself enunciated that
they kill you and they think they're
offering service to God now that is just
one example of the inversion the moral
inversion that this represents Isaiah
said woe to those who call evil good and
good evil there is no group to which
that more that better applies than the
Islamic State
today and not only do they kill and
think that they're offering service to
God but they also proudly avow that they
love death and this is one more Quran
passage in chapter
62:6 it
says oh you who are Jews if you
arrogantly claim that you you are God's
chosen to the exclusion of others then
long for death if you are truthful if
you claim that you're God's chosen
people the Quran says to the Jews then
long for death now that's a very strange
thing to say and some people might say
well that just has to do with a
willingness to be a martyr and that
might be all there is to it except there
are under other indications that there's
more than that involved the Islamic
jihadis of the Islamic State and other
groups Al-Qaeda and others like them
they have many many times affirmed over
the years we will win because we love
death more than you love life we love
death more than you love life zart Saray
the Boston Marathon bomber when he was
captured when he was almost captured he
was in that boat do you remember he fled
to a pleasure boat in the suburbs and
was hiding inside it and the police were
closing in and he found a Sharpie in the
boat and he started writing on the
inside of the boat and what he wrote one
of the things that he wrote was we look
into the barrels of your guns and we see
Paradise because we love
death
now loving
death is obviously the opposite of the
Christian Spirit and the idea of loving
life of God being the author of life and
we love life and we love creation
and we love the
manifestations of the human spirit that
celebrate those things another thing
that the Islamic state has done that you
may have seen in the news is destroy
Priceless and irreplaceable Assyrian
artifacts 2,000 3,000 years old that
they came into control of and going into
the the museum in mosul and smashing
them to bits and you may have read that
this was uh to avoid idolatry but nobody
was really worshiping old Assyrian
winged horses and that's not really what
it was all
about chapter 3 ver 137 of the Corran
says go around the world and see what
became of the civilizations before you
and that means go around the world and
look at the ruins because the ruins are
testimony to the Judgment of Allah that
these these civilizations were
idolatrous and were unbelieving and
Allah punished them and destroyed them
and so and who how does Allah punish and
Destroy unbelievers by the hands of the
Believers so if Allah is punishing and
destroying the unbelievers by the hands
of the Believers and showing thereby his
power and the Quran commands you to go
around the world and look at the ruins
and see what became of the civilizations
that rejected the LA then there's
another Divine responsibility that the
Muslims have to create ruins to
destroy because that in itself shows the
power of Allah so you have a group like
the Islamic State that loves
death and that loves
destruction and that denies the
cross and denies the Redemption of
Christ and hates women you have probably
heard about i w I'll spare you all the
revolting details but the sexual slavery
there's a very peace in all places the
New York Times today about the uh
Islamic State's practice of sexual
slavery and how it's based on the Quran
and so much else that shows that we are
facing in that a quintessential
anti-life force a quintessentially evil
force a force that is perhaps a more
concentrated evil than has ever before
been encountered in history and that's
not excluding the Nazis or the
Communists although they certainly rival
it and
so the Islamic state has very often said
that it's coming down to the end it's
considers that it is preparing for the
Twilight battle the last struggle
between good and evil and they see
themselves as the good and even their
magazine is called davik which is a town
in Syria where in Islamic tradition
that's where the arm get battle between
the forces of good and the forces of
evil will take
place they see all this in those terms
and I believe that they've got a point
in that and that we need to see this in
those terms as well not necessarily not
to be presumptuous and say oh yes this
is the end of the world I think it's
always good to be cautious about
prophecies like that and applying them
to our own age but certainly that this
is a challenge to the church
and to Christians each individual
Christian such has never been seen
before and or at least has not been seen
since the very early Roman
persecutions and that we are called upon
now
to understand exactly what's at stake
and to know that the stakes are indeed
very high that this group and groups
like it are going to keep coming no
matter what and they're going to keep
advancing because they have imperative
to rule the world in the by their own uh
statements they're going to keep
advancing until they're
stopped and how and when they will be
stopped well a lot of that of course
will be a military thing but it's also a
spiritual
battle a spiritual battle requires
spiritual weapons it requires not only
prayer and fasting the two things that
the Lord said about the most virent
demons there this kind can only be
driven out by prayer and fasting
but not only that but also something
that I think is very much lacking in the
west today and that we each have a
responsibility to try to restore and
that is an understanding of an
appreciation for what judeo-christian
western civilization has brought to the
world students in schools nowadays in
public schools all over the country
you're I'm sure you're aware of this are
more often than not taught to be
embarrassed at being an American and
being embarrassed at being a Christian
or coming from a Christian background
and understanding that all that means is
racism and
oppression and these things coales very
nicely with the Islamic State's agenda
and with the agenda of Islamic
supremacism in general that a group that
does not appreciate what it is who they
are and what it has and what it has done
is not going to defend
itself and a group that cannot
understand the value of what it is
brought to the world doesn't even have
any desire to defend
itself and yet this is the
civilization that has brought we are the
children and Hees of the civilization
that is brought to the world Concepts
that we take for granted that we think
are as natural as breathing the freedom
of speech is the Cornerstone of a free
Society the concept of the equality of
dignity of all people before the law
that's a quintessential Christian
concept stemming from the idea that we
are all created in God's image and
endowed with his
Spirit there is no other religion that
teaches that in the Quran 48:29 it says
Muhammad is the Apostle of Allah those
who follow him are merciful to one
another and ruthless to the
unbelievers and it says in chapter 3:
110 to the Muslims you are the best of
people on Earth the best of people
whereas in chapter 98:6 it says of the
unbeliever the unbelievers among the
people of the book that is the Jews and
Christians who don't become Muslim are
the vest the most vile of created beings
now that's not the idea of the equality
of dignity of all people the equ that
from which comes the idea of the
equality of Rights of all people before
the law these things are foreign to
Islamic societies and there's a very
good reason for it they're not taught in
Islam and you add to that the
institutionalized discrimin ation
against the people of the book and you
see even more reason why these societies
are so stratified and do not have
concepts of universal
justice these things are our own
patrimony and it is very very important
it is there is nothing else more
important than that we impart
them with the faith and with an
understanding of History to to our
children our children's children and
help them to see that there is a very
big difference contrary to the popular
cliche today in what whether you believe
one thing or another and it does matter
what you believe it does matter the
content of the assumptions that you
bring to the world and that the the
beliefs that come from the Quran are
beliefs that lead to hatred and viol
vience and oppression does this mean
that every every Muslim every believer
in the Quran is hateful and violent and
oppressive of course not if you think
about the Christians that you know you
know that there are some who are very
devout and very knowledgeable and some
who are
neither and every gradation in between
and it's the same thing with Muslims if
the Quran teaches something it doesn't
necessarily mean that any individual
Muslim has any knowledge of it or any
interest in it but that doesn't mean
it's not
there and that we need to understand
that it is there and that what is going
on in Iraq what's going on in Syria
what's going on in Indonesia in Pakistan
in Egypt and elsewhere where Christians
are being persecuted today it's not an
accident it's not a retaliation for
American foreign policy it's not a
response to
depredations uh real or alleged of the
United States or of the state of Israel
it is something that is based very
deeply as I've tried to show briefly
today on quranic imperatives and as such
it's not going to go away as long as
there are believers in the Quran there's
not going to be any kind of dialogue or
negotiation or concession that will
change
it what we can what can change it of
course is the power of the
truth in so far as we ourselves have the
courage to stand upon that truth without
the slightest compromise and without the
slightest deer and without slightest
hesitation in the face of what are
certain to be in the coming days and
months and years increasingly virent and
even violent
challenges and so the good news is is
that we know how it ends up and we know
that we will win we know that life
always triumphs over death we know that
life will never be entirely extinguished
and that you know uh even in Soviet
Union at the times when it was most
violent and oppressive Soulja nen wrote
about how there were little movements
here and there what he called Blades of
grass through the concrete that showed
that the spirit of freedom and the
spirit of life and the true Spirit of
service and love for God will never be
extinguished from the human
Spirit but getting from here to there
it's not going to be a very easy ride
and there are hard times ahead and of
course uh we have abundant warnings
about that and abundant advice about how
to deal with it in this in in in
Christian scriptures and so that
ultimately is where we can find the
answers to this tremendous Challenge and
it is indeed a tremendous challenge we
have the best of all fighters on our
side in the Lord but we have to be
willing to stand for him no matter what
as he stands for us thank you very much
m
please be seated our schedule calls for
a time of Q&A uh with uh Robert Spencer
and uh if you'd like to ask him uh some
questions uh that perhaps have Arisen as
a result of what you've been hearing
please go to a microphone and we'll
we'll call on you and we'll allow him to
address your
ISS Tom emry from Redeemer Lutheran in
aaso Michigan uh Dr spenc there have
been
persistent reform movements within
Christianity is there any such a concept
you think possible or likely within
Islam it's always possible I'd never say
it's not possible but likely I think not
uh in Islam there is the idea that the
Quran was delivered in perfect form and
there is a passage where Allah says to
Muhammad this day I have perfected your
religion for you so if the religion is
perfect what what needs reforming
reformers also in a context in which the
penalty for apostasy and heresy is death
it's very hard to get a reform movement
going because the reformers keep getting
killed uh it's you could say well you
know Christianity went through times
like that and it was because a kindly
Prince uh gave Martin Luther shelter and
so on but there have not been any such
in
Islam Mahmud Muhammad Taha was a studin
reformer in
1985 and he taught that the peaceful
passages of the Quran should supersede
the violent ones and he was executed for
for heresy by the Sudanese government in
1985 akmed Aid is a a l spokesman in
Morocco nowadays and he taught the same
thing just recently uh earning him a
death FAA from the Moroccan clerics and
he's now living in hiding so it's very
difficult to reform given those
circumstances anything is possible but
it's it's very unlikely and it's very
foolish of the western governments to be
putting their hope in that reform which
they're doing now yes
sir I can hear you just I'll repeat the
question
e e
has what has what led to
it oh yes okay
sure I'll I'll I'll take the second
question first in case you didn't hear
it it was about uh the war in Iraq and
did I believe that the war in Iraq and
the top Ling of Saddam Hussein has
contributed to the current chaos and
there's no doubt about it yes certainly
this is obviously not the intention of
uh the United States in toppling Saddam
Hussein but it uh was I considered and
the problem is is that there are no good
guys in that battle Saddam Hussein was a
vicious and brutal dictator but without
a vicious and brutal dictator what you
have in Iraq are three former ottoman
provinces that all hate each other kurd
Sunni Kurds Sunni Arabs and Shiite Arabs
and there's no Iraqi nationality it's
it's a fictional country like Yugoslavia
or Belgium that has no uh cohesion no no
natural cohesion either ethnically or
politically or religiously and so uh
without a strong man it's going to fly
apart and given the context you're going
to have Sunni Shiite strife and attempts
to impose Islamic law on the Christians
and that's exactly what we got I think
the Bush Administration and the Obama
administration because they both have
subscribed to these politically correct
fantasies about Islam being a religion
of peace they did not have any idea any
of this was going to
happen uh but should have uh the first
question reaza aan is a very popular uh
Muslim writer and apologist who makes
part of his uh makes it part of his
business to assure non-muslims that
Islam doesn't really teach Warfare or
hatred or uh any of these things that we
see committed in its name all the time
which only begs the question of why is
it that so many Muslims are
misunderstanding Islam in such a severe
Manner and all in the same way uh but in
any case I find the question very
strange because the gentleman asked it
said that in his book no God but God
which I admit I have not read uh he says
that the Byzantine Christians were not
even considered people of the book does
that mean they were considered worse yes
uh I don't think that that's
historically accurate um the as a matter
of fact if you read going back to
sephron of Jerusalem who was of course a
Byzantine Christian in the 7th Century
who according to Legend turned over the
keys of Jerusalem to the Cale of Umar
Umar lays out precisely the regulations
that the people of the book have to
follow for living under the Islamic
society and they are a constant of
Byzantine history after that point so I
think that that's uh if that's indeed
what re oan says it's a strange thing
for him to say since he's usually saying
everything is Rosy but it it's it's it's
not inconsistent with his record to be
inaccurate um if you actually if you
uh if you look at uh my website Jihad
watch I have just a few days ago a whole
long catalog of his egregiously false
statements that he makes but he has the
right opinions and so he keeps making
more he gets Christianity WR too thank
you very much thank you yes sir Jean
Grim from presc Arizona in light of this
talk about the religion of Peace would
you say something about the doctrine of
abrogation
between Mecca and Medina text sure uh
chapter 2 verse 106 of the Quran says
when we agregate or cause to be
forgotten a verse then we will give you
one that is good or
better we being God so he's saying if we
cancel out a part of the scripture we'll
give you something just as good so don't
worry about it now that obviously is a
passage that was invented by somebody
who's making it up as he goes along and
he's contradicting himself and then he
has to explain how is is how it is that
the immortal God is contradicting
himself and so he's canceling stuff out
it doesn't uh apply the uh Islamic
theology generally understands this to
mean that chronologically later passages
that were considered to have been
revealed later in Muhammad's career
cancel out ones that are earlier if
there's any contradiction the most uh
frequently cited example of this is
alcohol there's a passage in the Quran
that says don't come to prayers drunk
that's all don't come to prayers drunk
which implies that you can be drinking
just don't come to prayers after you've
been eming
overing then there's a passage that says
there is some good in alcohol but the
bad outweighs the good and so it's
getting worse and then there's the
passage that says alcohol is from
Satan so don't drink it
so this is considered to be a
progression easing the Muslims into the
idea of the prohibition the total
prohibition of alcohol okay that's fine
it's a little bit odd that it would say
that there's some good in it and then
that it's from Satan but we can leave
that
aside later on you have the problem of
the violent passages and the peaceful
ones in the beginning of Muhammad's
career According to Islamic tradition he
was a preacher of various religious
ideas he did not have any political or
military power and he taught tolerance
it was actually tolerance of himself
self he wanted the Pagan Arab
establishment of Mecca to tolerate his
group when he moved to Medina later in
his career and became for the first time
a political and military leader then he
began to teach Warfare first defensive
Warfare and then offensive Warfare and
there are various passages regarding all
three in the Quran and the general idea
is the same that because the passages in
joining Warfare come later than the
passages in joining tolerance the
Warfare is valid for all
time and applies for all
time nowadays though you hear people you
hear Islamic spokesman like R oon and
others say that Islam is a religion of
peace and they quote all these peaceful
passages from the
Quran what they don't tell you is is
that those very passages are considered
to have been aggregated in Islamic
theology by more violent
passages and they only apply when
Muslims are in a situation comparable to
the situation of the Muslims in Mecca so
when the Muslims are a small group that
is weak and has no political or military
power then they preach tolerance that's
the situation in the United States today
but as they grow they become more
aggressive and start preaching warfare
that's what we're seeing in Europe now
and it'll come here again
soon come here as well soon yes than
you was my question um but I'm glad that
you went on that that line of answering
because now given given concerning
alcohol I'm so glad I'm not a Muslim and
a Lutheran
Canadian so uh so I'm going to have to
think of another question I have I
actually had two so I'm gonna ask you a
more simple one first in in Nazi Germany
there was a symbol that was used for
those who who were Jews and that
actually did not come from mat Germany
did it came from actually from Islam is
that not correct yes that's correct it
came from the kff mut in the 9th century
who uh made the Jews and Christians put
symbols of
over the doors of their
houses and uh made them wear special
clothing and the Jews clothing was
yellow and the Christians was blue and
this was to mark them so that a Muslim
coming down the street would not say
assalamu alaykum peace be upon you to a
non-muslim because that's forbidden in
Islamic law in Islamic law you say you
say if I see you if we're both Muslims
and I see you I say assalamu alayum
peace be upon you and you
sayum or and also upon you not with you
upon you but if you see a non-muslim
coming you say peace be upon those who
are rightly guided that is peace be upon
the Muslims not on
you and so the kale mut made the
Christians and Jews wear distinctive
dress so that they would not get the
Islamic greeting by mistake and so that
they could be marked very easily for the
payment of this tax and so on so if I
can ask one short question in place of
the other one that he stole from me um
if could you explain if your
understanding at all about the discovery
of the first uh um Quran in in Yemen and
the implications it has for uh for the
Quran yeah you know I guess you've heard
about the uh the the original Quran or
the the very early copy of the Quran
that was recently discovered uh in
Birmingham England actually and it was
uh carbon dated couple of pages of
chapters 18 through 20 of the Quran and
found to be dated between uh
54 I think 5 550 to 575 to 650 and so
everybody was amazed because this would
obviously make it the one of the
earliest qurans and people were going on
in the BBC about how the person who
wrote this might have been taking
dictation from Muhammad himself and so
on Muhammad uh is supposed to have died
in 632 and the Quran collected in 6 53
so if this is dated from 570 to 650 it's
it's very early but one thing that the
people who made a big deal about this
didn't notice or didn't pay any
attention to was that 570 date Muhammad
is supposed to have become a prophet in
the year 610 and died in the year
632 so if this document could have come
from between 570 and 610 it might not be
the Quran at all it might be some of the
bits that were taken to make up the
Quran yeah because the Quran itself
Bears very many signs I wrote a book
about this a few years ago did Muhammad
exist available at any self-respecting
bookstore and in
it in
it the Quran there very very many
strange things about the Quran but in it
it shows very many signs of heavy
editing and as a matter of fact there
was a re another recent manuscript
Discovery in tuenin in Germany that uh
was dated from in in the
670s and they published page after page
of it online and I was just amazed
looking at it because you see all these
places where stuff is erased and other
things written over it and I thought
this exactly confirms what we I and some
others have been contending that the
Quran is a a a composite book made up of
other older material that was cobbled
together to create the holy book of this
new religion see uh if you look
historically there Muhammad is supposed
to have died in 632 and by the 690s the
Muslims rule from from Spain to
India and yet if you look in the
Contemporary records of that period
there is Nar aention all the while the
Arabs are conquering everywhere nobody
mentions these people came in with a new
prophet and a new holy book and a new
religion nobody mentions that can you
imagine these conquests were supposed to
be energized were supposed to be
inspired by Muhammad and the Quran and
in 60 years of those conquests nobody
mentions Muhammad or the Quran or Islam
and the people who are conquering aren't
even called Muslims by the people who
they conquer and who leave records as to
what happened sophronius of Jerusalem
who I mentioned before being one of them
he's supposed to have taken Umar around
the city and so on but in his own
writings he never mentions Muslims he
never mentions Umar he never mentions
that they came and said we have a holy
book we have a new prophet none of that
he shows no sign that they are anything
like that and it what it seems if you
look historically is that Muhammad is an
invention like Robin Hood maybe a
historical figure but one on whom a
great deal of Legend has been overlaid
and the Quran is a is a is a creation by
committee to create a religion and why
is this religion created because the
Arabs conquered all this all this land
in those days you didn't have
constitutions you didn't have
parliaments you had a single unifying
religion the Byzantine Empire was
Christian the Persian Empire was
zoroastrian the religion unified the
empires the Arabs amassed this huge
Empire they needed a religion to hold it
together and they made that religion
Marshal and expansionist imperialist and
belligerent to make sure that those
virtues so to speak would be inculcated
into those into their people so as to
make sure the Empire would be continue
to be strong and expand and so anyway
this discovery of this supposed ancient
Quran actually only undermines even
further the standard Islamic story of
the origins of Islam yes sir yes oh
sorry yeah um Doug dner Anapolis area
Lutheran Church Anapolis Maryland uh
first of all I grieve that people who
speak the truth like yourself have to
have such heavy guards surrounding them
all the time it's sad anyway my question
is uh a point of clarification you were
talking about the Christians of mosul
living for 14 00 years in relative peace
and then that changed was that because
simply they were not required to play to
pay the jizzel jiz the what what I meant
was this when they lived under the
caliphates the umaya the Abbasid and the
ottoman caliphates they did pay the
gizia and they were sub subdued they did
submit to Islamic rule that's when they
lived in relative peace now it was
always a very very tenuous piece and
their lives could be forfeit at any
moment for a perceived infraction but it
wasn't the wholesale destruction that
you see today what happened is then the
abolition of the gizia the abolition of
the dimma in in
1856 is followed by a period in which
the Christians live almost as equals
with the Muslims in that area but when
the Islamic State comes in and wants to
reassert Islamic law they demand the
jiza from the Christians the Christians
don't want to pay and so then they're
considered kufar hary infidels at war
with Islam and thus they have to be
killed and that's what's happening now
that's why these ancient communities are
being destroyed now I'm sorry about
those who uh I apologize I shouldn't
have been so long-winded but anyway
thank you very much
[Applause]
we've come to a time of a break but I'm
going to give you a choice if you'd like
to hear the report of the ballot first
and the election uh very good then we'll
uh proceed as you have decided uh Pastor
Carl Johnson of our election uh
committee could you bless us with your
presence um your humor is optional uh
but but the ballot report is necessary
the office of the bishop for a four-year
term number to be elected one number of
valid ballots
386 number necessary to elect we have
some TSA approved white smoke
baby powder's the best I could
do uh Bishop John brosi 321 votes Pastor
James Layman uh 65
votes I declare Bishop John Bowski
elected to the off office of Bishop of
the North American Lutheran Church for a
four-year term
I'm so grateful for the honor that You'
bestowed on me in the past and that I
get the chance to continue to
nurture and develop these
relationships the next four years also
serving as your Bishop it is my
privilege uh and my hope that I can also
a blessing to you and your congregations
as we continue to serve Christ together
and to lift up his name to give
expression to the truth and wonder of
his word thank you so much for this
opportunity God bless
you executive Council clergy fore term
number to be elected one number of total
ballots 383 number of invalid ballots 11
number of valid ballots
372 number necessary to elect
187 votes received Pastor Carl
rasmuson
131 Pastor Eric Waters
129 Pastor Paul re 68 Pastor Tom puck
44 those pastors then that will appear
on the next ballot include Pastor Carl
rasmason Pastor Eric Waters and Pastor
Paul
BR executive Council lay fouryear term
number to be elected one number of valid
ballots
371 number necessary to elect 18
votes received Rosemary Johnson
212 Steven Lord 15 159 there is an
election I declare that Rosemary Johnson
is elected to the executive Council for
a four-year
ter executive Council lay toe term
number to Ed one number of valid ballots
369 number necessary to elect
185 votes received Brian Sutton
224 John
Elling 145 there is an
election I declare Brian Sutton elected
to the executive councel for a two-year
ter
at this time we we continue with the
second ballot if the tellers would come
forward
andap e
before we cast our next
ballot I'd like to read from Matthew
chapter
7 our lord Jesus says ask and it will be
given to you seek and you will find
knock and the door will be open to you
for everyone who asks to receive he who
seeks finds and to him who knocks the
door will be
open let's join in word of Prayer
Almighty and most gracious God we thank
you
for these Disciples of Jesus Children of
yours willing to serve in leadership we
thank you for the elections that have
taken place thus far and for the those
still on the ballot before us we ask for
your spirit we seek to know your will we
knock knowing that you open doors so
guide us as we cast our votes that our
decisions would be consistent with your
will in Jesus name
amen uh there is um one ballot and
because there's one ballot remember
please mark one name and one name only
that's a very important we had to throw
away 11 ballots that were where people
marked or voted for two
people for
as we are voting um it's my duty to
report to you that in the interest of
full disclosure I have not been
bribed however the offer is still
open it it's only A10 million cashier's
check payable to the North American
Lutheran Seminary endowment
fund and if you'd all like to take up a
that would work
too in the interest of time uh we going
to ask uh for our general secretary to
bring us a report from reference and
councel and make two announcements while
you're filling out your ballots
committee on reference and Council
received two resolutions uh by the 1M
deadline one having to do with the
election process for the um Bishop of
the North American lual church and
another one having to do with Planned
Parenthood the recommendation of the
committee on reference and councel is
that uh time permitting uh we try to
address both resolutions uh later on
this afternoon before dinner um of
course there may not be enough time but
if if at all possible we would like to
uh begin with uh the resolution on the
election procedure uh for the office of
Bishop and then the two announcements um
if you're interested uh in joining in a
week of confirmation Camp uh in June of
2016 you will bring your confirmation
students to join with other nalc pastors
and students in the beautiful North
Carolina
Mountains so
um and I highly recommend that our
congregation is a part of a confirmation
camp that was just completed and Pastor
Luke said it was just fabulous and Paul
and Murray also so uh anyway with
pastors Justin Colm and Bill white
please stand so here's Justin and
where's oh they're right next to each
other ah so see them uh if you're
interested in joining together for a
confirmation camp in June of
2016 tonight um after uh dinner uh
you'll see that there's uh what looks
like a long list of recognition of
anniversaries but that is not going to
take a whole lot of time uh Steve Bell
is going to uh do um what he does so
well not only sing his music but uh
really um uh preach the gospel to us and
Inspire us
and uh there's plenty of time set aside
for that so if you were thinking of of
oh no I'm going to stay away from this
it's going to be a long boring night uh
we strongly encourage you to stay for
dinner and stay for the full agenda of
events outl after that thank
you last call for ballots are all
ballots collected
and now declare this ballot closed and
we are in recess for 15 minutes we'll
see you back here quickly